there's nothing quite as fast rating of
a bad movie ending failure to stick that
landing in the final act can totally
ruin an otherwise great movie or give us
one more reason to hate one that was
already a dud here's a look at some of
the most annoying movie endings in
recent memory and it should go without
saying but spoilers ahead Matrix
Revolutions
The Matrix trilogy always tried to be
more of a thinking person's action
flicks and your average comes through
kick fest so it didn't exactly come as a
surprise when the second and third
installment took a deeper look at the
complex ideas behind all the action
still it was pretty disappointing when
the series was capped off by a confusing
blur that went from hand to hand combat
directly into all the explained Eastern
mysticism look when you end up needing
fan sites and the message boards to try
and explain the ending of your trilogy
you've clearly done something wrong
x-men the last son for the third film in
a successful x-men franchise screen
rights of Simon Kinberg
and Zach pen tried to bring the force by
consumed and killed a team grey the Dark
Phoenix to the big screen unfortunately
budget and studio limitations prevented
the filmmakers from adapting the comic
story properly and fans were left with a
lackluster version of the tale the
restrictions made the deaths of crucial
characters virtually meaningless and the
movie's big emotional moment was
completely undercut by our confusing
post-credit scene sure the movie made
money but The Last Stand was so widely
disliked that ass and the entire x-men
franchise into limbo for years signs
there is no shortage of movies to pick
ting hostile aliens invading our planet
but somehow it's a story that needs
constant retelling this is likely
because it's been quite effective and it
seems that you've got to really go off
the rails in order to screw it up can -
- an island can handle crashing bloggers
sadly that's just what M night Shyamalan
did with signs the film is very well
cast and for the most part tells an
effective story but unfortunately all of
that goes out the window
this alien thriller revealed that the
aliens one big weakness is friendship
and cuddles I'm just kidding it was
actually just water earth is over 70
percent water so isn't it a little
strange that an alien species advanced
enough to travel across the galaxy and
try to take over a planet would pick a
destination covered mostly by a
substance that can destroy them perhaps
gamilon will one day reveal that the
real twist of science was that the
aliens were on a self-destructive
intergalactic mission that would make a
lot more sense the amazing spider-man 2
what do you get when you try to depict
one of the most emotional moments in a
comic-book characters history while also
setting the Pulu of studio mandated
spin-offs if you guess the cancellation
of the third movie in the trilogy you're
right the last acts of the amazing
spider-man 2 was a mess as it tried to
squeeze in killing off Emma Stone Gwen
Stacy right before rushing into a climax
that dealt with the twin dangers of
electro and the Green Goblin as if that
wasn't enough the movie also tried to
fit in a tease for Sony's then planned a
sinister six standalone feature like a
lot of subpar superhero movies it all
ended up being a lot of noise of not
much emotional impact and the negative
reaction killed the franchise and sense
the quippy webslinger swinging right
back into Marvel's welcoming arms now
you see me there's nothing quite as fast
rating as a dumb movie that thinks it's
smart and now you'd see me is a perfect
example of a confident idiot I am smart
I am smoke hey there Markey I mean yes
there may Archie films that rely heavily
on sleight of hands and double-crossing
or a lot of fun but while they're busy
with their tricks they often forget to
tell an actual story and that's exactly
what's happened here so the final act in
which Mark Ruffalo's FBI agent character
reveals himself to be the shadowy figure
behind a secret order of magicians is as
absurd as it is boring the most
infuriating part of all is that the
movie has a fantastic cast behind it and
it's hard not to imagine the angry
people sitting in the theater feeling
like the movie had played a trick on
them I am Legend they say the third
time's the charm
but that sadly proved not to be the case
the Richard Matheson's classic novella
I am Legend
after a pair of poorly made adaptations
Hollywood had a chance to finally get it
right with I am Legend in 2007
unfortunately even after more than 40
years
Matheson's tale of a scientist living as
a last man on earth still turned out to
be too dark for studio execs the biggest
problem the movies third-act in which
the main character comes to understand
that instead of being humanity's final
hope he's actually a monster in the eyes
of the planets new civilization after
test screening audiences rejected the
original ending you know the one that
was in the actual book it was based on
director Francis Lawrence had to reshoot
it verse turning a potentially
thought-provoking picture into just
another forgettable CGI editors demo
reel Man of Steel some people hate it
some people love it but regardless of
where you stand there's no denying that
Man of Steel has one of the most hotly
debated movie endings in recent memory
some fans were on board with director
Zack Snyder's over-the-top climactic
battle which ends of Superman's nothing
general Zod's neck but many moviegoers
who grew up with Superman felt that his
decision to execute the movies villain
was unnecessary and even downright
offensive Man of Steel's ending also
received serious backlash for the amount
of destruction and death it brought
flying through the core of Metropolis
the giant box office numbers while
suggests up fans love this movie but
just about any film about Superman is
going to make money but maybe that's not
the best measuring stick although it
wasn't as critically panned as Batman
vs. Superman
I smile Man of Steel definitely
presented an ending that have many fans
up in arms Lord of the Rings The Return
of the King generally speaking there's
nothing wrong with the way the Lord of
the Rings saga conclude Frodo completes
his quest the Rings gets all melted and
everyone lives happily ever after yet it
seemed like director Peter Jackson
really didn't want the movie to end as
the conclusion seems to drag on and on
before finally cutting for the end
credits when you look at the series of
scenes that slowly plays out over the
last act of The Return of the King it
seems like the movie just doesn't want
to like go away and just when you think
the movie is finally over you find
yourself sitting through yet another
leisurely look at life after the fall of
Sauron instead of feeling satisfied at
the end of a story well told lots of
fans found themselves getting bored
while a bunch of hobbits jumped around
on a bed in slow motion damn those slow
motion hobbits
thanks for watching click the looper
icon to subscribe to our YouTube channel
plus check out all this cool stuff we
know your love to
[Music]